[Música]
e
el 24 de febrero el mundo se paralizó
para millones de ucranianos tras meses
esperando una invasión rusa la guerra
había empezado
[Música]
el catering aus a nova es una joven
informática que vio su vida quebrarse de
madrugada
cuando leí de las bombas al principio me
sentía frustrada frustration
no sabía qué hacer y pensé que no podía
irme a ninguna parte porque no tenía
sitio alguno al que ir al fatah hernán
pérez tocó toda su vida estaba en kiev
sus hobbies amigos y planes de futuro
todas las copias son 11 años de mi vida
tengo un hobby que es grabar vídeos esto
es algo que no podía dejar atrás
no es la primera vez que caterina tiene
que huir en 2014 escapó de crimea desde
entonces convive con el miedo
el tengo la sensación de que no importa
donde vaya rusia vendrá otra vez y
tendré que irme otra vez no siento que
exista un lugar seguro en ninguna parte
engaño ahora la historia se repite con
dimitros beats una alerta en el teléfono
y las llamadas de familiares en shock
alertaron a este joven abogado del ibi
protesta pasa me desperté a las 6 y en
mi teléfono que la guerra había empezado
no me lo creía pero recibí muchos
mensajes de amigos y familiares y vi los
ataques en kiev zhytomyr y pando
franquicia
esta parte intenté entenderlo pero no
podía
ver esa noche durmió en su despacho
porque su apartamento está cerca del
aeropuerto
las sirenas antiaéreas siguen retumbando
en cada recoveco de este país el drama
humanitario se suma a la destrucción que
provocan las bombas y la artillería
vidas congeladas y martirizadas por una
guerra